have you been in love before  have been in love  yes what's more important Do You Love or  Money  love  but love is hard to find when you're a  sex worker no matter what level you're  at  definitely hard  um because people  and it's totally understandable men  don't want to share right most men don't  want to share so  sometimes they say like that's okay yeah  I can do that and then they realize they  can't do that  and part of it is me just not even  trying because  um  oh now we're getting like more personal  instead of just like my basic life that  I've had to say a hundred times to  interviews  um  I put myself out there for dating  after I left the ranch and I fell first